-You feel the love there?
-Dude, I am so underdressed.
You didn't tell me
what I was following.
Are you kidding me?
-Sorry. There's John Oliver
feathers around.
I apologize if you're allergic.
-No apology.
I actually ran into him earlier.
He tried to sell me a CD
at Times Square
in that same outfit.
-Yeah, that wasn't him.
That wasn't --
-That wasn't?
-That was Elmo, yeah.
-Oh, got it.
-But I want to talk to you about
everything in your whole career,
but I want to get to know
you a little bit, too.
I just want to say,
your ProbleMATTic World Tour --
you announced it.
And in 48 hours,
you sold 600,000 tickets.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dude.
-Insane. I know. I know.
-What does that feel like?
-I mean,
it feels incredible, man.
I went from -- I mean,
literally, July of last year,
I was considering
quitting comedy and everything.
I couldn't sell any tickets
at any comedy club.
I wasn't getting
any kind of break.
So, from going from
playing clubs for 35 people
who got free tickets to we broke
Ticketmaster, which is insane.
So, yeah, Travis Kelce,
if it doesn't work out,
holler at your boy.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-It's been unreal, man.
My entire life has changed
in a matter of like 14 months.
I'm so grateful.
-I heard about this story.
I kind of related to you because
you started comedy around 15?
-Yeah, 15. Yeah.
-Wow!
-My my grandpa used to take me
to the Columbus Funny Bone
in Ohio every Wednesday,
and it was a bringer show,
like a lot of open mics are,
where you have to bring --
-Oh, a bringer, yeah.
-Yeah.
Usually, like five people
who have to pay for tickets.
-The way it works is,
if you go and perform,
you have to actually
bring five people
that buy tickets and buy drinks.
-Yeah. And hope they laugh.
-And hope that they laugh.
Yeah, they just want business.
-Oh, of course.
-They don't really care about
your career.
-No, not at all.
And all my friends were still
in high school, obviously,
so they couldn't come attend.
So my grandpa would
buy five tickets
so the club would think I had
five people there to perform.
And then he would just watch me
tank week after week after week.
-He was the only guy?
-No, but he loved it, though.
He was my biggest supporter.
Like, if it wasn't
for my grandpa,
I'd have absolutely
no sense of humor
and I never would have got
my start into comedy.
So --
-Got to give it up for grandpa.
-Oh, thank you.
-Good to have that support.
-Thank you, thank you.
-What -- Do you remember
what your set was
when you were 15 years old?
-Oh, nonsense.
Not stand-up at all.
I also, for the first six months
of doing stand-up,
had no idea what a set was.
Nobody told me.
I would just go up there
and do five minutes
of, like, ridiculous things
over and over again.
But it was never like kid stuff.
I never was -- I was never
telling, like, school jokes.
I was never making,
like, poop jokes or anything.
-No, it wasn't --
-It was always for adults,
because I was a kid performing
for adults in a comedy club,
which I think inevitably
helped me transition,
because around the time
I was like 23, 24,
people start looking at you
a little bit differently.
You're no longer,
like, the novelty of like,
"Oh, he's a kid,
give him a chance."
At 24, people were like,
"We paid to get in here.
Make us laugh."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So I think that helped
that transition
be a little bit smoother,
that I never really played
into the young aspect.
-And you were saying earlier --
I'm sorry that I went over it --
you were thinking
about quitting?
-Yeah. Yeah.
Dude, I mean,
I had been doing comedy
for 11 years as of last year,
10 of it in L.A.
And it's just --
It beats you down hearing,
like, so much rejection.
Like, I couldn't get
a special anywhere.
I couldn't get on
a TV show anywhere.
"The Jimmy Fallon Show."
-Oh, my God. Wow!
-I know.
I submitted a couple times.
We'll talk after.
-Okay, yeah.
-No, all of these things
just weren't adding up,
and after a certain point,
you go, "Am I delusional?
Like, maybe I'm not funny.
Maybe I'm not
supposed to do this."
And then just one random video
kind of changed everything.
-Yeah, it was a TikTok video.
-Yeah. I reluctantly started
posting on TikTok
beginning of last year.
I've always hated social media.
I think it's so negative,
and it just stresses me out.
But one day, I was just like,
"How long can I go against
the grain and it not work?"
So I started
posting sporadically.
And then I was at the
Just For Laughs festival,
which is, like,
the most notorious
comedy festival in comedy,
besides the
New York Comedy Festival --
-Where I got my start.
-Is it really?
-Yeah. New Faces.
-No way. Never got New Faces.
-Alright, well --
-I know, I know, I know.
So, I'm at this festival,
and even that was
a funny circumstance,
because over the pandemic,
my friend Paul Elia,
who is one of my best friends,
great comic --
we developed this show over the
pandemic that was a dual-hosted,
improvised show.
-Yeah.
-And Just For Laughs wanted to
pick up that show
for the festival,
but they didn't want me.
They wanted Paul and not me.
And Paul, being a good friend,
was like,
"I refuse to do the show
without him.
Absolutely not."
So they said, "Well,
we're not going to pay him.
We're not going to pay
for his travel.
But if he wants to perform,
he can perform."
So I was like, "You know what?
I'll swallow my pride.
I want to experience
what this festival is about."
We went. It was arguably
the best show of the festival.
But before that show,
the same night,
we were at dinner, and I was
about to post this clip
called "The Lazy Hero,"
which I had already edited.
It was at a show
in Phoenix, Arizona,
for like 75 people,
and I was just sitting there.
I was so depleted and depressed
at, you know, being at a place
I wasn't even invited
to perform at.
And I was like,
"This is so stupid.
Why am I even
bothering posting this
if it's not going
to do anything?"
And my friend was like,
"You already edited it.
Just post it, and then
we'll have a fun time tonight."
And then that video,
over the next couple of days,
went insanely viral,
like 20 to 30 million views.
And then that made every other
video on my profile go viral.
And then everything just kind of
exploded out of nowhere.
-30 million views.
-Yeah, dude. Insane.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Insane. Life-changing, man.
I'm so grateful.
-Isn't that wild,
how that happened?
-The irony of something
you dreaded doing
changing your entire life.
So take more chances.
-Yeah, that's a good thing.
Yeah, take more chances.
Why not?
Yeah.
-Yeah.
-But I also love
how people go like,
"Oh, Matt Rife --
yeah, overnight success."
-12-year overnight success, man.
It takes forever.
But you have to look back
at those moments,
and all the times
you thought you were ready
for a certain opportunity,
you probably weren't.
Now I'm in a position right now
where there's a lot of pressure
to stand behind what I've built
on social media
in my live performances,
and had I not had
these years
of training leading up to it,
these shows might not be
as good as they are now.
Now I feel like
I'm in the proper position
at the proper time.
-Good for you.
-Thank you.
-I'm happy for you.
-I'm a fan. You're very funny.
-Thank you so much.
-You have a new special
November 15th on Netflix.
-Yeah, yeah.
"Natural Selection."
-"Natural Selection."
-You were supposed
to say it. I'm sorry.
-No. No. We both should say it.
"Natural Selection."
-"Natural Selection."
You guys say it?
-"Natural Selection"!
-Now everyone's saying it.
Alright, this is fantastic.
-You're so fired.
-I know, yeah.
You shot it in D.C.
-Yeah.
-Why D.C.?
-D.C. has always been
my favorite city
in the entire country.
I love it there.
It's a beautiful city.
I'm obsessed with history.
I've been to all the museums
dozens of times.
-It's kind of fascinating.
-The parks there.
Yeah, I'm obsessed with it.
-What was the venue?
-It's the Daughters of
the American Revolution
at Constitu-- Cons--
Constitution Hall,
if my mouth decides to work.
And I got an opportunity to open
for Dane Cook there in 2019,
and I fell in love with it.
And I had already done a little
bit of research on the venue.
It's where Eddie Murphy
filmed "Delirious,"
which is arguably one of
the greatest comedy specials
of all time.
Robin Williams
did a special there.
Katt Williams
Presidents have spoken there.
And it just has this amazing,
like, Colosseum-esque theme
to it that I just really thought
captured what we're trying
to get our point across on,
on this special.
So it was inevitably
the best possible location,
and I couldn't be
more proud of it.
-Oh, yeah, it looks gorgeous,
and it's very funny.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Matt Rife
in "Natural Selection."
Take a look at this.
-Get this through your head.
Astrology is not
this magical life guideline
that predetermines
your future in the stars.
No, none of that.
Your future is dependent
by your own thoughts,
opinions and actions.
You are in complete control
of how your future turns out.
It's not up here. It's in here.
The whole time, it's up to you.
It has nothing to do
with the stars, man.
Just because Jupiter has a ring
and you don't doesn't mean...
doesn't mean that's who you're
supposed to look up to
for all this
magical advice, man.
-Come on. That's what I'm
talking about, buddy.
Matt Rife!
"Natural Selection" premieres
November 15th on Netflix.
Congratulations.
-Thank you so much.
-Come back, please.
-Really, thank you so much.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Stick around, everybody.
Matt Rife.